ce jeudi 14 février les yvelines seront
placés en vigilance rouge pour fêter la
saint valentin
certains établissements proposent des
prestations spéciales pour accueillir
les amoureux à versailles le trianon
palace a vu grand et propose différents
package dont un à partir de 500 euros un
prix qui comprend notamment une chambre
luxueuse décorée pour l'occasion dans ce
package là et donc inclut aussi un coeur
croquant des dix benghanem donc c'est un
coeur en chocolat blanc fournis et garni
de confiserie aussi toute cette maison
tout comme le coeur et vous avez bien
évidemment le lit parsemé de fleurs de
rose de pétales de roses pour pouvoir
justement rester dans le cadre intime et
feutrée de l'hôtel l'hôtel propose
également aux clients des cocktails
spéciaux à base d'alcool de fruits
rouges de liqueur de chocolat ou de
fruits de la passion des ingrédients
choisis pour créer une ambiance
romantique dans ce lieu datant de 1910
nous avons décidé de l'infini pau a
décidé de créer un dôme de glaçons pour
pouvoir mettre en avant aussi les fruits
en entier qui sont mis en valeur aussi
dans le cocktail si vous voulez déclarer
votre flamme dans un lieu historique
datant du xiiie siècle château de
villiers le mahieu organise un repas
spécial saint valentin le 14 février au
soir dans ses rangs par les
propriétaires proposent également aux
clients de passer un week-end dans l'une
des 98 chambres du site à partir de 349
euros
au programme séances de spa pour les
couples avec massage en duo et activités
en plein air sur les 22 hectares du site
beaucoup d'activités sont bien sûr à
votre disposition vous avez des vélos
vous les empreintes et lorsque vous le
souhaitez des trottinettes mais
également afin de passer un bon week end
en amoureux des barques puisque nous
avons la chance ici au château de
villiers le mahieu d'avoir des douves en
eau si vous êtes d'humeur casanière est
plutôt ambiance coin du feu la ferme de
grignon situé à côté de plaisir propose
pour la première fois cette année dé
coffret spécial saint valentin entre 15
et 40 euros
cette boîte gourmande a été imaginé
pendant plusieurs semaines pour rendre
l'atmosphère chaleureuse
c'est romantique mais
russie cor est vrai dire un petit peu
champêtre donc non il y en a qui va être
plus décidé à faire un petit repas avec
un plat cuisiné une petite terrine en
entrée quelque chose comme ça et après
c'est plus sûr de se faire un cadeau
voilà une petite terrine un petit mienne
des choses comme ça dans un palace dans
un château ou bien chez soi le plus
important reste avant tout de raviver la
flamme pendant une soirée et peut-être
plus